[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Leo Wilcox from Anchorage
Alaska and I'm a bike rider but Leo
isn't just any bike rider she rides a
lot for the past three years I've ridden
20,000 miles each year that's right
every year she puts more miles on her
bike than most people do on their cars
which is pretty insane think about it
this way the circumference of the earth
is 24,000 901 miles around so for each
of the last three years
lael has nearly ridden around the globe
sometimes it can be painful
riding that much riding that much it's
never boring for me and I'm not sure if
I feel obsessed with riding miles I just
wake up in the morning that's what I
want to do you know the other way you
could look at is people are obsessed
with their work they wake up and they go
to work and they want to go to work I
guess I wake up and I want to ride my
bike Leo is an ultra endurance bike
racer and she's one of the best I
started racing about three years ago my
first race was a 400 mile road race a
friend put me up to it I signed up three
days before and I won the race
unexpected I was borrowing my mom's road
bike and I just never really got tired I
rode through the night and I actually
picked up my pace as I finished she
sense ridden some of the longest and
toughest races like the 2015 tour Divide
which runs 2,750 miles along the spine
of the Rockies two started I actually
rode from Anchorage down to Banff
Alberta to the start no big deal
she only added on an extra 2,100 miles
that year laya clocked a new record for
women 17 days one hour and 51 minutes
but she thought she could do better so
later that summer she rode back to Banff
and retraced the route finishing in 15
days 10 hours and 59 minutes she was
just getting started
the next year she raced across the
country again from west to east as a
trans America bike race from Oregon to
Virginia 4,400 miles and I won the
overall race men and women I caught the
leader in the final
and beat him to the finish it took me 18
days yeah I mean I just stay on the bike
that's how I win but I'm just pretty
relentless and not wanting to waste time
that's because these races are
completely unsupported there are no team
vans no catered meals no massages so
you're basically on your own to win lael
pretty much never stops riding she keeps
everything she needs packed in bags all
over her bike extra socks long johns
sleeping bag she says she'll be here is
the rainfly for my tent food jar of
peanut butter snacks and coffee and
essentials bike tool dental floss
toothbrush toothpaste and spoon my
wallet but Lael doesn't carry shampoo
because showering is a wasted time in a
race the longest I've gone without a
shower 17 days and my hair was like one
single dreadlock and I went into a gas
station in Montana I'd taken my helmet
off and I went up to buy my three
breakfast burritos and two gallons of
chocolate milk or whatever I was eating
and the woman was like hon you really
got that windswept look sticking
straight up so from that point on I did
not take my helmet off in public it's
just what you do if you want to win I'm
very good at conserving time I also
don't need to sleep that much and that's
another part of these races most people
sleep four or five hours max everybody's
body's gonna hurt things are gonna go
wrong not every moments gonna be fun but
you are gonna see a lot of beautiful
things along the way now Leila is
preparing for a new series of challenges
including a thousand mile race across
Switzerland and another in Kyrgyzstan
and when she's not racing she's still
riding she guides cycling camps she
established a new route in Mexico's Baja
Peninsula and then there's her personal
project to ride every road in her home
state my summer project has been riding
all the major roads in Alaska and I'm
almost finished at this point I think
I've probably written about forty to
forty three hundred miles I probably
have another 500 to go lil knows most
people don't entirely understand her
love of peddling but that doesn't bother
her
well they do think it's crazy yeah I'm
not recommending other people ride this
much and not telling everybody they
should do what I do I just do it because
I want to racing I'm driven to to do my
best to try to win but otherwise I just
want to be out there
[Music]